let's just start with the word
serverless now you know when i first saw
the word i kind of was like oh that's
kind of a weird name um i think it's
infrastructure-less honestly because i
think of
infrastructures i guess everything's
running on servers somewhere but you
know there's the things that we do but
i think to get a sense of what
serverless means for all of us as as app
developers or just people who are just
building things right
i'd like to go to the past you know i i
i grew up with this rotary phone over
here on the left-hand side i
i didn't like friends who had a lot of
zeros in their telephone number because
it was really painful i know some people
probably never even seen those things
but a telephone is a telephone
and and you know along came you know
wireless technology you know for our
house and then really for you know broad
kind of you know cellular technology
right and so you know the whole wireless
principle was applied to the telephone
you know the telephone is still the
telephone it's just wireless now
um it still does the same function
allows us to communicate with people
it's just wireless now right and so we
think about the concept the concept like
the core item hasn't changed however the
way in which we deliver it has
i guess yeah i don't know iphones and
our smartphone's a little pretty far
away from phones but in fact i hardly
even use my phone as a phone anymore so
it loosely works
um electric it's another kind of way of
thinking about this you know i think you
look on the left-hand side it's like i
understand this engine i could
troubleshoot it i could work on this
probably with my brother he's a bit more
he's a bit better at engines than i am
um you look at this middle one well
there's lots of servo motors and you
know like this is the kind of the my car
now i don't have no idea what's going on
there and then on the right hand side
well that's the motor and electric car i
have no idea what's going on
doesn't matter a car is still a car like
to the user to your audience the people
who are actually going to actually
engage with this this item
car is still a car it gets me from one
place to the other right it has stereo
it has four wheels maybe it won't have a
steering wheel eventually right i mean
auto driving seems kind of interesting
and fun right so we're taking electric
and we're applying it to the principle
of a car right or the core item of a car
and you know i argue that the same thing
is going on in the serverless
and if we think about serverless and
what are these principles that were
taught that were
that were tying to our applications
i i think of this is a paradigm right
and it really comes down to
you know little or no uh manual server
management and there's always going to
be some level of management when we
deploy applications right um you know
automatic elastic scale
built-in resilience because if it's a
serverless thing it should just be there
and if i have to actually engage with
the with the thing
to make sure that it's actually a fault
tolerant that's an issue right uh it has
to be always available and has to be
instant and i think this this last
bullet is probably the one that i think
is changing uh the minds of a lot of
people around service and really coming
down to changing the way that we that we
that we use and and buy software as as
developers and the way we actually
you know run these things i i i love the
content the concepts of consumption
based bait you know billing you know
what is my monthly bill i don't want to
deal with you know buying a license for
something for a year i only use it for
like two months out of that year
it's wasted compute especially in the
day and age of us having you know these
large bills to large you know cloud
providers how do we actually minimize
and become very efficient with our
compute and only have like kind of
consumption based you know rating and
building for around these things and i
think if i think about those four kind
of core principles of serverless that's
pretty cool and i think
we've come a long way with serverless
serverless you know we have these like
these these compute platforms you know
fargate as your services i i really love
google cloud run i think it's pretty
cool you can you know take any
containerized app and just throw it at
google cloud run and it'll scale that
thing up and down it it's pretty slick
y'all i'd go check it out um but it's
kind of just managing the infrastructure
underneath
and then there's this this emerging
group of of companies that are doing you
know serverless functions again you know
the big three all offer that but then
you know i think about you know cloud
fireworkers and netlify and these sort
of things i'd love netlife i think
netlify is super cool where it's more
event driven uh you know it's a function
that a developer can call and it just
basically spins up spins down as used as
as needed it's just a function that
basically as you code just sits in a
directory
um and i think these serverless
functions are pretty pretty cool
and i love that the concept of service
functions in the concept of lots of
things that we do um and then there's
these kind of these larger serverless
app development kind of platforms that
are that are starting to emerge where i
think they're putting it all together
they're getting compute the functions
the whole thing and i think you know we
start thinking of like the modern ide
and what is that going to look like you
know do we get to the point where you
know we're kind of doing some of these
things i i do believe that that this
this kind of
next generation of app development is
happening and and it's really because i
think some of the things that we've seen
over the past two years of building
serverless and and and using this and
the value it can provide to to to people
use these things now
when you start to deal with data
um
things get a little bit more complex
when you
well
within a serverless environment or
without right like when you start to
deal with that with data you have to
start thinking about you know great i'm
i'm resilient and i'm fault tolerant but
to what level what's my failure domain
is my failure domain a region is it is
it just an a z is it is an entire
kubernetes cluster
how do i survive the failure because
these things do go down right um how do
we scale these things so that they can
actually you know if it's serverless
well i don't want to be serverless
within
a single region i mean you know how do i
expand beyond regions you know and and
for databases you know the transactional
guarantees get really really tricky here
because if i have you know a person in
new york writing a record and somebody
in sydney writing the record at the same
time who wins how do you how do you deal
with these kind of conflicts and so
there's things you have to do in the
software to actually mitigate these sort
of things
um but if you take this and you take
those serverless principles and now
let's apply it to you know the database
and then that's what we're going to use
as our example here well in a database
in the old world you know we sharded
database you know we had you know two
instances of a database you know
multiple shares so we got scale we're
doing the synchronization between two
sites maybe there's a primary and a
secondary one in one region another in a
secondary region or maybe i need
coverage in europe so i have you know uh
this sharded full database thing going
on in
u.s west and then i got something over
in europe and i'm doing synchronization
and i it gets really complex
in this modern world this becomes more
of a distributed platform right and we
start to apply these principles to this
distributed mindset so that you know
each entity is kind of part of the
bigger hole and that's how you get
serverless because
scaling big massive pieces up and down
down to zero it's near impossible to do
that it takes you know
10 people or even two people to do that
that that's too much
serverless is about automation it really
is and it's how do you automate these
things and so when we think about the
the concepts or the the the core
primitives of our of our application how
do we break them down so that we can
scale them separately
and that's really the trick behind
serverless now the service database
again the data creates big challenges
how do we auto scale um putting data
close to users so they have low latency
access to that and thinking about these
transactional latencies right
ultimately i feel like serverless and
the term should be infrastructureless
because
these are the things get get really
complicated um you know scaling across
regions these sort of things are are
really tricky
i think ultimately the end game of
service is about i think i you know it's
the value to the user whoever is using
these sort of things and for developers
i think it's about starting instantly
it's about eliminating the need to
manage upgrade operate no operations
right i don't want to deal with scale
and i want to completely eliminate
downtime i don't think there's a
developer in the world who wants to even
think about any of those things on the
top of this of this of this slide i
think what we want to do is just build
um you know i think we want we want
transactionals we want data to be
guaranteed consistent we want it in real
time um and i think ultimately the the
end game of this at least for us at
cockroach labs and we think about a
serverless database you know if we
really think about that and and you just
have an api against that database with
endpoints around the planet
could the database be something simple
as a sql api in the cloud i don't even
have to think about any of these things
and if we remove the stuff across the
top of the slide and we start to just
build and code against the database just
as an api things get really interesting
and i think that's the like to me that's
the ultimate vision of kind of what what
serverless can do for the database and
so you think about that what what could
that mean for you and your application
where you're just some
blank blank api in the cloud right and
and that's you know for us it's a sql
api in the cloud
now let me actually i'm going to
actually give a little quick demo here
be you know why not i mean you know i'll
go on a limb here
so i'm gonna go to cockroachlabs.com
and you could spin up a cluster using
our serverless instance right now i just
need to log in i just hit the sign oh
i'm already signed in
and so it's really as simple as create a
cluster we have serverless or dedicated
dedicated is uh you know full instances
where we have sres managing it it's
private our serverless instance is
multi-tenant you choose a cloud provider
choose a region right now we're aws and
google cloud um
and and you set a spend limit
now this comes back to the
consumption-based billing um and and as
consumption-based billing becomes kind
of more more important
understanding consumer behavior around
that is actually pretty important we've
gone a long way to think through this
and and for us it was like well let's
just put limits in place so that you
know
you're never gonna spend more than ten
dollars a month if i put ten dollars in
my spend limit or zero it could be
completely free forever and for us that
means well i have to throttle usage of
the database over time what does that
mean for your application because i
don't think anybody really likes to get
a bill at the end of the month where
some
service just ran wildly for you know 20
days and i get charged you know
thousands of dollars right and so i
think as we build these things we as
developers need to be uh cognizant and
aware of of what people really want and
for us you know having spend limits was
was a big deal um and then we just named
the cluster so i could just create a
cluster um it's going to be ready in a
couple seconds here and what's happened
in the background i'm going to show you
exactly what's happened
um
so i'm going to create a user generate
and save password yep great and i'm
going to hit next i have a cluster up
and running and i have um you know i
have a complete set of
connection strings uh i can use a
general connection string parameters i
can use the cockroachdb client
all these things basically what i have
is i now i have a postgres cluster i
have a postgrass instance basically it's
a cockroachdb serverless instance we're
wire compatible with postgres so any of
those kind of postgres tools you would
use or drivers they should just be able
to connect to this and so you're just
going to use the the connection string
or parameters i use parameters when i'm
using a bunch of different tools or just
use the cockroachdb client and now you
have a complete uh relational database
um that is resilient it's going to do
auto scale and i'm going to show you
what it does underneath cover so
quick demo basically is it's pretty easy
to get basically a cockroachdb cluster
up and running um there's lots of more
information on our website about what
cockroachb does how it's different than
other things but ultimately i think in
the simplest form it's kind of like
postgresql but automate all the scale
eliminate the concept of of downtime uh
online schema changes upgrades all that
that's really kind of the the big stuff
of what it does so so that's the quick
little demo i encourage you all to go
out and check out a cluster so it's a
pretty easy to get going so
okay so let's talk about architecture
let's drive into kind of how we did what
we did and this is really the top of
this so
a database is really comprised of three
layers there's a language there is a sql
execution layer and there's storage
every database really is kind of
developed and thought of in this way
and really ultimately any one of our
applications can be thought about like
this right like there's an api with my
application okay sir is it a ui is it
just some basic you know rest api i
don't know like that's the language like
that's how you communicate it does
things and it stores data to disk
literally a database is just like every
other application they're a little bit
more complex
they're not easy to build i'll tell you
that right now um but they're all kind
of like this now in distributed systems
you know i think there's databases on
the right hand side you know we have a
distributed database you have to start
thinking a little bit differently
because okay so the language is still
the language storage is still storage
but actually in storage am i storing
data across multiple different places
because remember this is a distributed
system this is no longer a monolith this
isn't like one server we're using many
many many right and so we have
distributed storage we have to think
about how we get data to that that's
replication and distribution distributed
execution becomes very important right
i can have a single instance of postgres
on distributed storage well i still have
a single instance all my rights have to
go through there i haven't solved a
scale problem right so how do you
distribute that for both
reads and writes well in our database or
how do you distribute your execution for
i don't know whatever you're doing in
your application and starting to think
about these concepts is actually pretty
important i think the shift towards
distributed systems is where these
things are happening so the divide of
where you cut your code apart to
actually make something serverless
is really between execution and storage
because if we think about serverless and
what we're doing at the storage layer
things need to persist they cannot be
ephemeral like they they need some sort
of a consistent existence right and you
need to make sure that those things are
up and running at all times right
whereas at the execution layer i don't
i'm not relying on something that needs
to be you know like it's in that in that
item right i'm just for us we're just
executing a query we're going to use
storage right and so
taking away and understanding what's
ephemeral versus what needs persistence
that's the that's the divide in your
application so look through your code
and figure out what what is those lines
do you need to re-architect things how
does it work for us we had to kind of
re-architect and tease these things
apart luckily enough it was pretty
modular in our code so we're is fairly
straightforward to do that but that's
the trick to really thinking through
things that are serverless i've talked
to you know lots of people building
serverless applications this is the same
pattern emerging across the board and i
think it's kind of one of these things
it's fairly simple once you see it
ephemeral versus persistence
scale ephemeral scale persistence in a
different way
and i think that's the trick right so
let's get into the storage layer
in the storage layer of what we're doing
it's a little bit different than some
other databases right like in in
cockroach and i kind of have to go
through kind of how cockroach works but
hopefully this is valuable to you as
well from an architecture point of view
just so what we had to do
ultimately in cockroach everything all
the data is stored in a kv and it uses
kv underneath now we translate kv to
relational so it's it's sql um but
ultimately you don't need to know what's
going on in this this logical key space
but every table is basically this huge
monolithic logical key space it's all
ordered right and kv allows us to do
some really interesting things and this
it's it's all ordered is is the key
thing this this lecture graphically by
key is the trick here
and so what we do is we take all the
tables and we convert them to kv
the k being a table name an index
the key and then a column name and then
the value is the value for that
particular column so let's just show how
that works here's a quick table it's the
dogs table i have an id i have name and
i have weight
and i have a bunch of entries
now this just looks like this is just a
table this is simple ddl
same thing in cockroach relational if
you're familiar with sql you get this
and this is what my data looks like i
could select all from dogs i'm gonna
this is what i'm gonna get back
underneath the covers what we do is we
actually when we actually store the data
at disk
we're gonna take and we're gonna
translate each row into these kv pairs
so okay here's the type the table name
is dog
my primary key is 34 for that then the
id right and then for the name
um
column i'm gonna have carl okay for the
weight column i'm gonna have 10.1 and i
just go down the line and so we're
translating records into kv
now if you look at the ordering of this
right
dog 34 name wait dog 78 name wait dog 95
so what we're ordering them so this
basically all gets encoded it doesn't
look like this dog 34 last name we're
actually encoding these things so that
we can actually get really really you
know efficient sorts so underneath the
covers and we know exactly where to
insert things into this ordered
lexographic pair now that's pretty cool
it's what allows us to actually actually
understand you know where tables are
when we start to actually move them
around excuse me i gotta frog in my
throat
excuse me everybody sorry about that
so what did we do to make this
serverless well if we're gonna use
shared storage underneath
what if everybody had a dog table i
wouldn't know which dog table belonged
to which person so
what we did is we just basically added a
tenant id to the key
and so now this is andy k's dog table so
what was my cluster i forget was like i
don't know
uh
sparkly kitten or something i forget we
come up with these funny minutes but
like that would be you know it belonged
to that particular tenant
and so what we do is we're just
appending that to the front of that and
so now
in this huge lexicographically ordered
kv set all of the records for that
particular tenant are together and then
inside there you know the tables are all
kind of sorted and then the keys and all
the stuff right so basically what we're
doing is we have um you know we have a
complete understanding across everything
and we're using one big shared storage
layer but the tenant key is what's
allowing us to understand which parts of
this data belong to who
um let's see here
there is a question that came through
what is the most appropriate naming
convention to label nodes on a
kubernetes cluster for instance
controller and responder well gosh i
don't know amara i'm not uh i that is an
interesting question i don't know i i'm
sorry i'm gonna have to i don't know i
don't know the answer to that sorry
about that
i wish i did i don't i don't
like y'all i live in this architecture
the application layer i don't get too
deep into like the the i understand how
kubernetes works but managing it is is
complex and kudos to all you who do that
um but maybe somebody else knows sorry
mr um all right so
that's great we just talked about the
storage layer we had to actually think
about what we were doing from a storage
layer we then had to think about okay
distributed execution we're already
doing that but how do we tie that to a
particular tenant
how do i make sure that you know jim's
execution is just mine right and this
sort of stuff right so again let's go
back to what we're doing in cockroach
and with this big huge key space and we
added um you know we added this whole
like the the the the the tenant to each
of the keys and this sort of thing um
and then basically what we're doing is
we take this big huge kv
range right and we or this big huge kv
sort and we cut it down into these
ranges which is basically these 512
megabit ranges and and and think of this
is like the way that we shard a table
we're just taking these ranges and
they're small enough that we can move
them around really quickly and and we
can and we can write them to different
physical nodes or different nodes that
are written in pods in a kubernetes
cluster right and basically that's how
we kind of distribute the data um and
that's kind of a key concept in in in
cockroach now
if you're going to do this we actually
have an index so we can have to find
these ranges you know so the first range
lives on these servers and whatnot and
so we have an index structure that
allows us to locate these things it's
very much like a b tree uh if you're
familiar with what that is um if you
want to check out how we do this our
code is completely open you can go check
out our git repo and actually check this
out
underneath the covers though we're using
something called raft i hope people i
hope many people on this are familiar
with raft if you're not
raft is a is a really interesting
concept as a as a developer and anybody
who's kind of thinking microservices and
distributed systems if you're on this
webinar thinking kubernetes um
definitely kind of check out raft and
see how it applies to what you're doing
but raft is a distributed consensus
algorithm now there's another one called
paxos some people use that as well
and what it does is it's it's
distributed system and it's gaining
consensus
it really allows us to get atomic reads
uh atomic rights and consistent reasons
what we're doing now what is raft raft
is basically it's an algorithm that
manages
um replicas of of whatever it is you
want to actually manage uh and write say
to disk
in our case the reason i have this
little like blue thing well this is that
you know this is that range that i had
before this is second range
so we basically break up our ranges and
then manage them using raft now we
create replicas of these so we have
three copies here within raft you want
three or five or seven or nine 11 you
know the odd numbers because you want
quorum so when i write to a raf group i
want two of three of these to commit i
want two of threes to say we're good and
then say everything's good because a
third will come along
or three of five right so it gets it's a
quorum-based transaction right so we get
this quorum and actually make all these
things work
also in in in raft there's a there's
this concept of a leader it's a special
replica and there's two followers all
the rights all the commands kind of go
to through the raft leader to the
followers and it basically manages to
make sure everything's good so that you
only have to ask one ref later it's like
great is this good yes it's good and i
can acknowledge back to the application
whatever it's doing it's going to have
this kind of authoritative up-to-date
answer for what's going on within within
that raft group right
um this also allows us to get atomic
replication so we're going to make sure
that this is going to happen like the
whole transaction is going to happen or
not it's going to coordinate with other
raft groups because i'm doing you know
i'm doing transactions across you know
maybe hundreds of ranges because maybe
i'm inserting 10 records or i'm doing a
select across different things and doing
joins like we can do this kind of
cross-shard transactions as well and
that ralph leader is going to manage
that it's going to help with consistency
and make sure that you know the the
atomicity in acid actually uh gets
committed okay so if you want to learn
more about distributed consensus you
want to learn more about raft um there
is this really wonderful website i
haven't been there in a while i i'm
pretty sure it's still going on uh
somebody probably would have told me but
the secret lives of data.com i'd go
check that out it's it they give a great
kind of visual representation for for
how raft works much better than i could
ever do so
um so we use raf then to actually
distribute data right so each raf group
right there's three of the copies
it's the same data it's that range we're
going to distribute them across three
different nodes in a system in
cockroachdb right and so that's what
we're doing we take the first range we
write it we take the second range we
write it we take the third range
what this allows for is kind of scale i
can know i could scale i could add more
nodes so i get more capacity
all of these nodes could service reads
and writes i'm highly resilient if i
lose a note i still have two of three of
the copies left right and so that's kind
of the special nature of what we're
doing and that's kind of that's helping
us at the storage layer
okay great so how do i kind of pull all
this together and and and now make this
serverless and this is the trick of how
you use kubernetes to actually do all
this okay
um but one second before i get this
there is a question
de bonchu writes is it possible to
allocate a network volume as persistent
storage to these nodes
cluster on-prem openshift cluster and
network volume ebs s3 or efs
um yes you're going to have persistent
storage and you're going to use
basically in kubernetes if i presume
this question you're going to use the
storage class and you'll just make a pv
claim
um from inside that pod and then you'll
use stateful sets within the context of
the the storage nodes like that where
you need to persist you use stateful
sets to actually maintain that
persistent connection between that pod
and whichever volume um you have
actually uh uh
you you have actually uh connected to
uh and then so each of the storage like
here within this context of this this is
us deploying a a database this could be
any application
um on on a kubernetes cluster what
you're seeing in the bottom those that
that color is this this is just a pod
and this blue box is is the is the is is
the application itself they're all
communicating to each other and so if i
wanted storage i'm just going to take a
mini storage class pv claim i'm going to
use you know stateful sets to actually
attach that to each one of these pods so
i can actually uh persist that demand
shoe so it's a great question it took me
a while to figure out the storage class
when i got first introduced to
kubernetes how this works so so for us
you know this is one single logical
database across multiple different
pods uh every one of these things can
can take
uh reads and writes this is just sql
uh you can do cross shard queries you
can do we can actually deploy this
across multiple regions and multiple
kubernetes clusters we can have one
single logical database which is pretty
cool right so you can like your failure
domain can actually go up to to entire
kubernetes cluster this was a database
that was built
literally on the same exact principles
as as kubernetes this wasn't like take a
database and do auto sharding and try to
make it work in this context
no this was basically built with the
same kind of principles and that's why
it works really well within this context
and using kubernetes to actually build
this out as a serverless cluster is
pretty cool and so what we did is we
said hey look at let's look at our let's
look at our stack our our
our layers within our product and we
basically took this kind of the the the
execution and how to find the data and
the the language and we put that in one
version and then we took the other side
and it was the storage of that data and
that's separate
and so what we're doing is we're running
a completely separate cluster of
cockroachdb that's doing storage only
and each of those kind of pods on the
bottom they have their own pv claim they
actually understand where that storage
is and i'm just communicating to them
they can they can service requests for
basically getting data and remember this
data is spread across all my users
across all their tables is now
distributed across
okay this is just three nodes running
into three pods but this could be
hundreds of pods and the sql execution
layer just works with this with the
storage layer to basically find that
data so lots of different data and users
in the bottom and then the sql the
execution at the top
and the sql execution part is ephemeral
so here's a virtual coster for a
particular tenant we have three
execution pods and it's just accessing
its data underneath
and i can scale basically the execution
now get really really efficient right so
you know tenant one needs three
different execution pods because of
their their bandwidth right
uh ten and two only needs you know
um
one tenant three needs three right and
it really depends on the
on the load
uh that that person has and that's a key
concept in with serverless right scale
up scale down scale to zero right
make it really efficient so you know
what did i get charged for well for us
it's how much storage and how much
compute you use right how many
transactions and that's really allow
we're able to scale these things
separately which is a key kind of
concept within serverless as we think
through these so so how does this look
in cockroachdb serverless we have like
the storage and replication nodes we
have more than one in each of the az but
you know we're doing a lot of them we're
actually working on making this you know
across multiple regions so you'll have
this across multiple azs and then
regions as well as beta right now it's
within a single region
you spin up you know so tenant one is
living on you know three different
availability zones so if i lose an
availability zone i still have other two
out of their paws to actually augments
again it kind of improves that resilient
nature so ten and two comes in as one
and then ten and three and so we're just
basically randomly you know deploying
them across different azs
now if you're going to do this you need
to be able to find
what it is is your compute layer right
what is where is this thing and so
you know we built a piece of software
which is basically a proxy which
understands where my tenant is so if i
come and ask any one of these proxies
that are that are in any one of these
azs running it knows it has a manifest
basically it says hey tenet one here's
where you can find tenant one's
execution layer and route that query or
route that request whatever you're doing
an application to that particular user
right so we tease out the ephemeral
compute from the persistent storage and
then you need to find things and we
built a proxy to do that really as
simple as that to actually build out you
know a serverless thing now data also
scales transactionals a transaction
scale as well so volume of data will
scale at the the persistent layer down
here in storage or replication we're
just going to keep adding capacity there
right
but but but this but the the ephemeral
compute that goes up and down based on
you know the the traffic right and so we
needed to you know accommodate elastic
usage deal with spikes and spin things
down to zero and this is all done via
these kind of ephemeral kind of sql pods
so we built this capability uh in auto
scaler and auto scaler basically is
looking at you know
each particular cpu for these pods and
understanding you know what a usage is
over the last five minutes we're looking
at peak cpu usage and all within the
context of a particular tenant right and
so if a tenant needs capacity we spin up
new capacity if they are not using it we
spin it down um if it falls to zero
we'll completely remove the tenant from
the cluster um and so that we aren't
using compute that we don't need to pay
for
so how does this look for so here's our
diagram from before you know we've
teased out the two layers um tenant one
my capacity my steady state capacity is
is average here up on the left hand side
it requires three ephemeral paws to deal
with that amount of traffic um but at
some point i get a spike
i don't know it's like 5 p.m and a bunch
of people come online and i'm getting a
lot of orders come in um and it's it's
going up and so what we do is we have
these things that we we have in each
each each cluster and and there's a
cluster in each availability zone we
basically have these unassigned hot pods
they're basically instances of my
ephemeral compute later that are just
unassigned so the proxy doesn't even
they just know they're there but they
aren't assigned to a tenant
and so what i do is i basically take one
of these hot pods uh in the proxy and
the manifest it says hey assign this to
tenant one and start using it i have
just scaled capacity like that
because these things are already up and
running it's up really fast i don't have
to worry about the time it takes for the
pod to start and then start the
application all these things it's just
running and unassigned and that's what
we did now when things return back to
steady state i spin that thing down and
if it goes all the way right it's like
middle of the night nobody's asking for
any transactions we scale that all the
way down so the auto scaler is actually
doing this in fact in the background but
then most importantly say a query comes
in
it wakes up that tenant and so we're
able to spin up a sql pod very quickly i
it's under a half a second and it's for
that first query that comes in i know
we're trying to drive that down to like
you know under 100 milliseconds under a
tenth of a second and so you know right
now that's that's kind of you know a big
focus right how do we get these up and
running really fast another big problem
you have to deal with in the serverless
world because well people want these
things to actually come up really quick
and so what we're doing is again we just
take this hotpot we don't have that
latency of spinning up the the
kubernetes the pod instance and we're
assigning that to a particular tenant
the proxy now understands that all the
proxies know where to go so if a query
comes in against any one of them it
knows where to go get that that that
tenant right and so
so that's that's basically how it works
that's that's what we've done to
basically take something what was a
distributed system fairly elegant but
then tease out this kind of ephemeral
compute side from this persistent
storage layer to make our application
serverless now
it was fairly straightforward for us
because well we were already a
distributed system you know so like
kind of applying these principles were a
little bit easier but i think if you
start from scratch thinking about this
like as you build your next application
how do you kind of tease these two
things apart and in the architecture of
your application makes a whole lot of
sense because you kind of prepare
yourself to apply the serverless
principles to whatever it is that you're
building and i think that's the that's
the trick and for me the big takeaway
again you saw me create an instance you
know y'all please go feel free to go out
and build your own
cluster it's pretty pretty easy to sign
up we're going to give you a free
cluster up to five gigabytes of storage
a month 250 million request units which
is pretty ample a request unit is just
basically an abstraction of a query all
queries are not similar you know like
select star from where
and you know join blah blah blah that's
much more query than select star from
customer right so
that's the way we do that uh and and and
it's free
so you can go out and do that right now
request units are interesting if you um
if you if you run out of request units
we don't actually you don't run down to
zero so you have no capacity we actually
reserve enough capacity so that you have
enough for the rest of the month so we
basically kind of throttle it so like
this last scenario is easy you have 8.64
million request units if you use
everything on your first day you have
that amount for the rest of the month
right so it's fairly good um from from
that point of view so
um so the the amount of what's the
chargeback model for this cockroachdb um
the charge model is basically you can
add a gigabyte of storage or 250 million
request units for additional i think
it's a dollar per i forget what it is
you have to go to the the website and
look at that but um it outlines all of
that um but but it's free up to up to
that certain level so
okay so that is all my presentation
um there weren't a whole lot of
questions i hope it was valuable to
everybody um i do hope to see people
live uh i'm i'm super excited to go to
kubecon
uh and be live with people uh in in a
couple weeks i'm also really excited to
go to valencia i gotta i would not
i would be lying if i didn't say that uh
you know the cockroach labs team will be
there we have lots of engineers who can
talk through these things with you we
can talk about our database uh as much
as you want as well we'll be giving away
things all these things um if you're
thinking about going i really look
forward to seeing people again live at
coupon it's the my favorite two shows of
the year are kubecon europe and cubecon
north america so i'm really looking
forward to getting back with everybody
so
um with that if there's no other
questions i wanted to thank everybody
for taking the time today i hope this
was valuable to you
you know i you know i hope i did a
little bit of a balance between us
talking about a database but kind of how
we thought about going through this this
serverless journey i really hope it came
i i really hope that was of value to
people so
um all right well thank you everybody i
really really appreciate it oh that was
my other presenter this morning that's
my friend rain oops i didn't fix this
slide so
um thank you everybody i really really
appreciate it and have